Which club has never lost a game when they lead at half time?
Right. You can ask me for the league,
I'll tell you. Right.
What would you. What would you.
Wait, hold on.
Would you be, like, ever? Ever? Bro,
we're still on beat until today.
Home and away. Home. Home.
Just home. Just at home.
Home gone. Wait.
And a Premier League team.
Oh, yeah,
cool. You got correct.
So it's a Premier League team.
Jeez. I know it is.
Do you actually? Yeah.
How would you know, huh?
How would you know? Don't worry. Okay,
I'll be honest. There's only one team that comes to, man.
Who's that? It's recent for.
It's gotta be Liverpool, I think.
I mean, I'm through.
I'm really gonna be winning now.
We. We.
Hey, calm down,
calm down, calm down.
Listen, just.
He's got confidence cause.
Yeah, cause they just won in it.
You might just be his teammate.
Yeah. How you feel about that?
It's not the best, but,
you know, we move on. Yeah.
You see the pulse interview?
Crazy. What do you feel about that day?
Coventry and semis is all that.
We're going to the finals.
Yeah. We're gonna win it.
We're gonna win it. Coventry beat.
You know, just crazy.
Then I'll be a. Sorry.
We're gonna win it. We're gonna win it!
We're gonna win it. Yeah!
Chelsea gonna be city and we're gonna be Chelsea.
This guy's confident. All right, cool.
What's Yours answers? Yeah,
I'm gonna say Liverpool.
Man United.
Amazing. The correct answer is